[Musique]
tim kendall ainsi un directeur de la
monétisation de facebook à saint
président de pin terrestre et pdg de
l'application momen ravi de vous avoir
avec nous j'ai tant de questions à vous
poser par quoi commencer pendant ces
pandémies le temps que nous passons sur
les réseaux sociaux a évidemment
augmenté
pensez vous qu'une telle utilisation va
perdurer où allons-nous nous débarrasser
de cette habitude
une fois notre liberté de circulation
retrouve il est difficile de prédire
l'avenir
je pense que nous avons assisté à une
telle explosion pendant qu'ils étaient à
leur domicile pendant sept ans et demi
parce que les gens n'ont pas
d'alternative il ne quitte pas souvent
leur maison ils ont de toute évidence
une vie sociale moins développés
qu'auparavant passage les parts sociales
je veux dire une vie sociale physique la
possibilité d'aller chez les gens ou de
visiter des endroits
je suis donc optimiste je crois que cela
va revenir un certain niveau
une fois que se terminera la folie du
confinement selon le documentaire
derrière nos écrans de fumée sorti cette
année consacrée à la menace que
représentent les réseaux sociaux ces
entreprises utilisent sur internet des
technologies pour gagner notre attention
qu'elles vendent ensuite aux
publicitaires mais voici la question de
quelqu'un qui a travaillé pendant
presque toute sa vie à la télévision la
télévision ne fait-elle pas la même
chose depuis des décennies nous avons
entendu les mêmes arguments contre la
télévision c'est du lavage de cerveau
c'est de la manipulation casser la jeter
à la poubelle
les réseaux sociaux ne sont ils pas tout
simplement une sorte de nouvelles
télévisions je pense que c'est une
excellente question
il ya plusieurs choses que je peux dire
à ce sujet la première est que la
télévision n'est pas aussi forte que les
réseaux sociaux pour ce qui est de
susciter une dépendance et ce pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord elle n'est pas
interactive et deuxièmement elle n'est
pas personnaliser
crainte le contenu que je vois à la
télévision ne parle pas de mon monde
social elles ne reflètent pas ma
popularité et ma position dans la
société
ça ne me permet pas de me comparer à des
amis ou collègues comme le font les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux e me
le permettent
il s'attaque vraiment à un tas de choses
et à mon cerveau animal
ce qui me rend vraiment accro si on
considère les données concrètes dans les
années 50
les gens regardaient la télévision
environ quatre heures par jour
aujourd'hui
ces statistiques sont en moyenne à peu
près les mêmes du moins aux etats unis
c'est à peu près 4 voyons la différence
avec les réseaux sociaux en 2010 les
gens passaient sur les réseaux sociaux
12 5 minutes par jour aujourd'hui il y
passe deux heures et demie par jour
enzo et scandent donc le temps par
personnes a été multipliée par dix en
dix ans alors que le nombre de personnes
utilisant les réseaux sociaux est passé
d'environ 500 millions à 3 milliards
sao et hills et et 6,9 donc en ce sens
cet explosif
c'est ça rend accro 1 1
vous savez les données sur l' influence
de la télévision sur la santé mentale
sont très différentes de celles sur
l'influencé des réseaux sociaux
si on considère l influence de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux sur le
bien-être mental
nous savons qu'il nous déprime nous
savons qu'il nous rende anxieux vous
dites que la moyenne est de deux heures
et demie j'aimerais bien qu'elle soit si
basse c'est dans mon cas c'est bien plus
que ça 2h30 ce n'est rien comparé au
temps que j'y passe
non mais nous sommes d'accord n'est ce
pas que ce concept attiré mon attention
et elle a gardé en la manipulant c'est
vraiment vieux c'est un vieux truc c'est
un vieux truc mais puissant si ce n'est
pas absolument vous savez probablement
que l'intelligence artificielle
en fait c'est déjà le cas avec netflix
et l'intelligence artificielle ne
définit pas seulement les
recommandations sur netflix mais aussi
une partie de la programmation le
développement et la création des séries
et maintenant pour partie guidée par les
données dont il dispose sur la façon
dont vous et moi regardons leur série et
en fonction de ce qui nous plaît et donc
je pense que c'est une question de temps
avant que la télévision traditionnelle
ne commence à devenir personnalisés à
tel point qu'elle attirera notre
attention par ses moyens je pense que la
télévision traditionnelle n'est tout
simplement pas aussi puissantes que les
réseaux sociaux pour capter notre
attention
human vous avez mentionné avant de
commencer cette interview que l'amérique
était polarisé comme elle ne l'avait
jamais été
et je vous ai répondu que le monde
entier était polarisé pas seulement à
l'amérique
vous avez également dit que les
conséquences politiques des réseaux
sociaux était effrayante et ce qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle pourrait
conduire à une guerre civile
mais je veux parler des médias
traditionnels comme fox news qui existe
depuis 1996 alors qu'il n'y avait ni
facebook ni youtube les médias cherchent
le buzz pour des meilleures audiences
plus il ya de sens mieux c'est la
modération et l'objectivité n
intéressent tout simplement pas les gens
elles ne suscitent pas d'enthousiasmé du
public
pourquoi disons nous que les grandes
entreprises d'internet doit changer
alors que nous n'avons rien contre le
fait que fox et msn bissy détruisent le
journalisme en amérique et polarise
complètement le pays craint trésor je
pense que tout a commencé avec le câble
ace was i was in fine c'est en 1996 que
fox cnn et ms nbc nous ont divisés en
différents groupes qui disposaient de
fait différente le ld versailles fax
nous disons que les réseaux sociaux sont
sous stéroïdes
parce qu'au lieu d'avoir trois versions
nous avons 100 milliards de versions aux
états unis
on le voit au sein de la gauche ou au
sein de la droite les républicains ne
peuvent même pas être cohérent et les
démocrates n'ont plus ils sont
complètement divisé et l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles ils sont divisés et
évoquer dans le film c'est qu'il n'y a
plus de concept de vérité
je n'ai aux craintes il n'y a pas de
concept de vérité partagée et je tiens
le câble pour responsable d'avoir initié
cette polarisation
je pense que vous avez raison de dire
que c'est un problème les réseaux
sociaux aggrave encore plus les choses à
cause des technologies de la possibilité
de créer votre propre cnn votre propre
réseau personnel d'information
mais le pin coin j'essaie ici
d'éclaircir une question aidez moi
j'essaie de comprendre si nous devons
pointé du doigt les géants de la
technologie où quelque chose de
particulier de plus précis par exemple
nous avons entendu des accusations
envers facebook qui aurait été utilisée
pour inciter au nettoyage ethnique en
birmanie mais une émission de radio à
l'ancienne à attiser quelque chose
d'encore plus grave le génocide au
rwanda et nous voyons les diffuseurs
être tenu responsable pas la technologie
elle-même
pourquoi traiter différemment les
entreprises technologiques aujourd'hui
voyez-vous ce que je veux dire
concernant les états unis et j'ai
témoigné devant le congrès à ce sujet
les etats unis sont de retour à 1996 à
peu près au même moment par coïncidence
le câble a commencé à nous diviser il
existe une loi qu'on appelle la section
elle autorise ces entreprises
technologiques à diffuser et publié tout
contenu sans en être responsable c'est
le communiqué x10 sensi actes
je peux me tromper sur l'intitulé mais
il s'agit bien de la section de 130 et
quand j'ai témoigné devant le congrès
j'ai appelé à examiner la section de 130
et à la modifier parce que vous avez
raison les agences de presse sont
responsables nous organisations
et vieux cesse ainsi vous dit quelque
chose de diffamatoires incorrecte du
point de vue d'un fait vous êtes
responsable vous devez en être
responsable si quelqu'un peut dire
n'importe quoi si n'importe qui peut
diffuser tout ce qui est populaire et
provocateur cela peut engendrer de
graves problèmes de société regardons
les choses différemment par exemple le
co-créateur du bouton facebook like nous
dit dans le film que son équipe voulait
simplement créer quelque chose de bien
qui encouragerait la bonne volonté
permettrait aux gens de se rassurer et
affirme qu'il ne s'attendait pas aux
dépressions chez les adolescents et à la
dépendance au legs mais la dépendance au
light n'a rien à voir avec un spa g
c'est juste la nature humaine n'est ce
pas je me demande donc si en quelque
sorte nous ne faisons pas de la haute
technologie un bouc-émissaire parce que
cela ne gêne trop d'admettre que notre
comportement est parfois trop moche et
si on arrêtait avec eux et facebook
comme responsable de notre vanité
facebook et ah oui je pense que j'ai
tiré de ce film deux conclusions ou même
trois la première est que les
entreprises doivent assumer davantage de
responsabilités
les gouvernements devraient probablement
intervenir si ces dernières ne le font
pas assez rapidement
et nous en tant qu'individu sommes
également responsable nous faisons des
choix qui ne correspondent pas à nos
intérêts oui voyez nous avons perdu le
contrôle de nos téléphones
oui pour plusieurs raisons que vous avez
mentionné
nous avons perdu le contrôle de nos
téléphones parce que nous les avons
laissés prendre en main notre vanité
notre besoin d'avoir raison notre besoin
de reconnaissance notre besoin de voir
les autres renforcer notre réputation
toutes ces choses sont en quelque sorte
des tendances humaine que les réseaux
sociaux exploite et nous avons la
responsabilité personnelle de faire je
pense des choix différents
si nous arrivons à la conclusion que ces
choses ont pris le contrôle de nos fils
de la même manière j'ai une
responsabilité si je bois trop en
pensant que j'en ai besoin
et il faut que je reprenne le contrôle
quand je me rends compte des situations
que cela engendre dans ma vie je pense
que c'est la même chose pour les
cigarettes c'est aussi vrai pour la
consommation excessive de sucre
donc je suis d'accord avec vous je pense
que c'est idiot je suis pas d'accord
avec les gens qui disent simplement
écouter ce n'est pas de ma faute ce sont
les réseaux sociaux qui me font faire ça
vous mentionner les cigarettes
vous étiez responsable de la
monétisation de facebook et vous avez
reconnu dans le documentaire avoir
contribué à rendre facebook aussi
addictif que la cigarette
je vous cite et sni figure de style ces
deux addictions sont le résultat des
mêmes processus dans le cerveau ce que
je voulais dire c'est qu'il y a eu un
moment où big tobacco et s'est rendu
compte de ce qu'il faisait
ils ont continué à le faire ils ont
continué à ajouter encore et encore des
produits qui rendait dépendance qui
donnait envie de fumer encore plus
n ce que je veux dire c'est que les
réseaux sociaux et en particulier ses
algorithmes de l'intelligence
artificielle feront la même chose
ils sont à la recherche de nouveaux
additifs à injecter dans les réseaux
sociaux afin que vous et moi voulions y
passer plus de temps parce que les
algorithmes sont programmés pour exciter
un peu plus chaque jour l'attention de
l'utilisateur et ses algorithmes
commence à réfléchir
ok comment peut-on faire ça il ya passé
deux heures et demie hier comment faire
en sorte qu'il y passe trois heures
aujourd'hui
donc ce que je voulais dire c'est que
ses algorithmes fonctionne et trouve de
nouveaux additifs comme le fait
l'industrie du tabac
si nous revenons en arrière tout a
commencé il y a dix ans
comme je le disais avec la popularité et
la comparaison
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un univers
différent celui de la désinformation de
la théorie du complot du contenu clivant
nous allons encore un peu plus loin dans
ce qui déclenche et implique vraiment la
partie la plus primitive de notre
cerveau
afin qu'on y passe plus de temps et que
l'on soit davantage concernés nous
allons faire une petite pause
nous revenons tout de suite pour parler
avec tim kendall ancien directeur de la
monétisation de facebook
ainsi un président de pin terrestre et
pdg de l'application moment
[Musique]
on nous sommes de retour avec ce week
end à l'ancien directeur de la
monétisation de facebook ainsi un
président de pin thérèse et pdg de
l'application au moment où se termine
dites moi quels sont les outils les plus
sophistiqués qui rendent les internautes
accros les ingénieurs et les grandes
entreprises technologiques utilise-t-il
sciemment les neurosciences pour nous
faire rester online non non je pense que
c'est en partie effrayant parce qu'il
n'ya pas vraiment sur ses plate forme
d'être humain de l'autre côté c'est
vraiment un algorithme qui à mon avis
n'est pas très bien supervisé qui reçoit
des instructions pour faire en sorte que
l'utilisateur passe plus de temps sur le
site on a cet univers composé 2 milliard
de contenus l'utilisateur à plusieurs
centaines d'amis qui publient des
contenus let's les algorithmes vont
trouver ce qu'il faut pour le séduire
tête qu intel
et il ya aussi les notifications push
ils peuvent jouer avec les horaires pour
envoyer ces notifications push
si quelque chose ne va pas il faut son
numéro de téléphone ils peuvent toujours
lui ai envoyé un texto et ce qui est
vraiment terrible c'est quand
l'internaute n'est pas revenu sur le
site depuis quelques jours si je ne vais
pas sur facebook pendant plusieurs jours
ou disons une semaine je reçois un texto
de leur part ou est ce un simple ils
font tout pour me faire revenir sur le
site
voilà donc les astuces l'une des choses
les plus efficaces que facebook a
découvert il ya 15 ans et est de vous
envoyer un e-mail disant regardez il y à
une nouvelle photo de vous sur facebook
il nous envoie pas la photo
alors voilà je ne sais pas pourquoi il
ne l'envoie pas pourquoi ne vous en
voyez pas la photo il ne vous envoie pas
la photo parce qu'ils veulent que vous
venez sur leur site pour voir la photo
ce que font d'ailleurs 100 % des gens
fois que vous y êtes vous resté plus
longtemps
et lorsque vous restez tout le temps ils
peuvent vous diffuser des publicités et
lorsqu'il vous en diffuse plus ils
gagnent plus d'argent
j'ai récemment discuté avec le père du
marketing moderne
l'économiste philippe cotler mais je ne
sais pas si vous avez entendu parler de
lui nous avons discuté du rôle de la
publicité dans l'insatisfaction
croissante que nous ressentons à la vie
elles nous imposent les dés que les
produits qu'elle propose sont ceux dont
nous avons besoin que sans eux
neuvy sont tout à fait inattendue les
réseaux sociaux fonctionne-t-il de la
même manière où sont ils plus complexe à
je pense que c'est plus complexe et il
na waie seul à fonctionner de cette
manière auparavant il choisit which was
étaient des cas d exploiter notre
tendance naturelle à comparer il
et ça marchait comme ça c'était comme ça
avec les premières publicité et le
marketing
regardez regardez votre vie tout
pourrait être mieux dans votre vie si
vous aviez acheté ce produit
c'est un moyen très efficace de
manipuler quelqu'un de l'amener à
changer d'idée et à dépenser de l'argent
aujourd'hui je crois que cela est allé
encore plus loin et a commencé à
vraiment déterminer si vous avez raison
ou non si votre vision du monde est
juste ou erronées 1,18 d'ailleurs ses
services tentent à vous convaincre que
vous avez raison parce que c'est bon
pour leurs affaires et des mecs ils vous
montrent contre les autres en vous
proposant des informations prouvant que
l'autre côté à tort et ils font inverse
de l'autre côté il ya de ça
nda c'est ça qui est effrayant
sean harris qu'on voit dans le film a
récemment dit une chose que je trouve
très intéressante
imaginons que vous ouvriez votre
téléphone et qu'il y a deux options un
flux d'informations qui vous montre des
choses qui valide fondamentalement votre
vision du monde
c'est à dire qu'elles prouvent que vous
avez raison et montre les choses telles
que vous les pensez f12 des tubes rift
enders et puis il y à un autre flux qui
est pour vous réellement un défi qui
vous propose des informations qui vont à
l'encontre de votre point de vue newsday
donc si vous croyez que la terre est
ronde
dans ce flux on vous fournira des
données illustrant que la terre est
plate
et pourtant on les gens ne veulent pas
lire ce deuxième flux ça ne nous
intéresse pas du tout
les gens ne veulent pas qu'on leur dise
qu'ils ont tort ils veulent que leur
conviction soit validé donc je pense que
c'est allé plus loin que tout simplement
vous convaincre que vous pourriez mieux
vivre si vous achetiez tel ou tel
produit
elle cherche maintenant à vous persuader
que vous avez raison et que les autres
ont tort non seulement qu'il est son
tort mais que ce sont en plus de
mauvaise personne
il y a une autre chose effrayante que
j'ai apprise dans ce documentaire je
vous ai entendu dire que malgré le fait
que vous avez aidé à construire tous ces
outils de manipulation
vous allez être devenue une victime
qu'est ce que cela signifie pour être
conscient de ce que font les réseaux
sociaux n'est-il pas suffisant je pense
que
comme avec beaucoup de choses qui
induisent une dépendance
il n'est pas très utile de savoir à quel
point son est faste
mais à t il 15 à 20 % des gens fument
toujours aujourd'hui
je pense que la principale raison pour
laquelle la majorité des gens ne fume
pas a moins à voir avec le fait que cela
laitue naksa qu'avec le fait que c'est
socialement inacceptable c'est du moins
mon expérience américaine 1 donc je
n'estime pas qu'il est nécessaire de
savoir que ça peut vous nuire à moyen et
à long terme ce qui peut être vraiment
utile selon moi utile à tout le monde et
c'est ainsi qu'on crée des outils qu'on
développe des applications dans ma
nouvelle entreprise moment ce sont nos
trois règles le principe de mount
consiste à vous aider à reprendre le
contrôle de votre téléphone
2 comment vous l'utilisez ps est prêt
fondamentalement nous vous aidons à
développer une prise de conscience du
temps que vous passez sur votre
téléphone
compte tenu des réseaux sociaux et du
reste la plupart des gens passent entre
4 et 4 heures et demie par jour sur leur
téléphone
mais si vous demandez à tous ces gens
ils vous diront presque tous qu'il n'y
passe pas plus de deux heures un
décalage entre la perception et la
réalité et il est crucial de le
souligner car cela montre une perte de
contrôle
à un certain moment vous vous dites oh
je n'ai plus le contrôle parce que je ne
perçois même pas correctement la réalité
la deuxième chose que notre application
vous propose ce sont différents moyens
de changer vos habitudes et 1.6 la
fonction la plus simple et qui est de
plus pour ce qui est de l'utilisation
des réseaux sociaux c'est un rappel et
n'emmener pas votre portable dans la
pièce sur vous dormez ici il suffit
d'installer sa comme règle c'est
difficile oh oui c'est difficile
vous savez quand je parle aux
journalistes ça leur semble vraiment
difficile c'est parce que la majeure
partie de notre travail se fait par
téléphone
en fait tous notre travail se fait par
téléphone particulièrement en ce moment
étant donné que nous travaillons tous
sur internet que nous ne pouvons
enregistrer des interviews en personne
et que nous ne voyageons plus pour faire
des reportages tout se passe par
téléphone je comprends à propos j'ai
travaillé par téléphone toute la journée
il faudrait que je vérifie combien de
temps par jour j'utilise mon téléphone
surtout après la sortie de ce film c'est
ça vous êtes donc le pdg de mômes end
une application qui selon la description
de votre site aide les gens à entretenir
des relations plus saines avec leur
téléphone oui donc et si je supprime les
réseaux sociaux de mon portable
de quelle manière ma relation avec mon
téléphone deviendront plus saine
parce que voyez vous je peux tout
simplement regarder twitter sur mon
ordinateur via hommes et bien tout
d'abord je ne vous conseille pas de
supprimer vos comptes
nous ne pensons pas que la suppression
des réseaux sociaux soit réalisable que
ce soit nécessairement la meilleure
chose à faire et nous cherchons tout
simplement à aider les gens à réfléchir
davantage à la fréquence à laquelle ils
utilisent les réseaux sociaux csn et
nous avons tous eu cette expérience on
prend son portable pour envoyer un email
vous regardez la météo pendant quelques
minutes
et puis en fin de compte il s'avère que
nous avons passé 45 minutes sur
instagram
on n'a pas besoin de nos portables pour
aller sur instagram et voilà quarante
cinq minutes plus tard je suis sur
instagram
je ne me sens pas mieux au contraire je
me sens encore moins bien je me sens un
peu coupable et j'ai l'impression de
n'avoir rien accompli
je regardais des photos de mes amis qui
ont manifestement une vie plus
intéressante que la mienne c'est une
mauvaise expérience mais je ne peux pas
vraiment en empêcher
on propose donc des moyens qui vise à
limiter ce genre d'expérience afin de
faire en sorte que passer quelques
minutes sur instagram ne soit pas un
problème en encourageant les gens à
apprendre par tentative par échec que
oui si je me limite à 10 ou 15 minutes
sur instagram
je me sens bien comment faites vous une
excellente idée mais comment ça marche
il ya et à huy se lit à deux choses
d'une part en général je pense qu'il est
utile de réduire l'utilisation de son
portable
c'est ce que nous aidons vraiment les
gens à faire parce que cela permet de
comment aider un journaliste comme moi à
réduire l'utilisation de son portable
nous vous donnons des conseils pour que
vous vous imposiez des limites
et puis il ya la partie la plus
importante qui est en même temps la
partie la plus récente de notre
expérience on vous demande de créer un
groupe sur momemt avec plusieurs amis
qui installe tous cette application
golf ensuite vous suivez un guide
pendant plusieurs jours qui vous aide à
prendre conscience et a joué à certaines
choses en groupe pour essayer de réduire
l'utilisation de votre téléphone
et pendant cette période nous vous
montrons à vous et à vos amis
comment chacun utilise son téléphone
seuil 10 l'idée est que les gens
changent leur comportement de manière
rationnelle
quand ils sont inclus dans un groupe de
personnes et c'est valable pour beaucoup
de dépendance comportementale
c'est ainsi que nous avons conçu et
développé cette fonction écoutez vous en
avez probablement parlé avec vos
collègues vous en avez probablement
parlé avec vos amis
accepter au moins de montrer aux uns et
aux autres la fréquence d'utilisation de
votre portable
nous constatons que cela peut contribuer
en soit à une réduction de son
utilisation car je vais sur le champ
télécharger mohmmad très bien très bien
merci beaucoup team et bonne chance pour
la suite
oui merci c'était un plaisir de vous
parler
[Musique]